[Musique]
j'ai fait la proposition cette année est
bien le gros groupe et le working des
pour l'ensemble plutôt que chaque ville
faisant dans son coin même si on
continue à faire ça mais malgré tout de
réunir 7 cet événement avec un
chapeautage on va dire entre guillemets
de communication de 51 en vie et tout le
monde a accepté donc c'est super bien
parce qu'il y en a qui commencent à 17,2
de 18-19 mais c'est sur le même week-end
[Musique]
c'est une forme de prise de conscience
elle est double cette prise de
conscience et une prise de conscience de
nettoyage bien sûr puisque avec des
pinces et des gants on va aller ramasser
les déchets mais ensuite il ya un script
qui va se faire c'est à dire qu'on va
avoir un moment de collecte à chaque
point d'arrivée et ensuite ya un prix
derrière qui va se faire
le principe c'est de partir d'un point
où on a un regroupement de personnes à
qui on distribue le matériel qui met qui
s'affuble bien sûr des gilets pour qu'on
puisse les repérer ne serait-ce qu'au
niveau de la sécurité et ensuite il ya
des circuits qui sont prévus eux ils
essayent de faire un nettoyage il n'y a
pas de concours 1 / pour savoir qui en a
ramassé le plus mais en règle générale
on pèse bien sûr à la fin de
l'expérience pour savoir combien on a pu
récupérer deux kilos